tu amor y está era capaz de defenderse
pero no se atrevió a pesar de ser un
antiguo campeón de karate en el colegio
vivió el infierno del acoso el y gime
como es llamado en japón durante años
sus verdugos fueron sus propios
compañeros
en el club de fútbol le ocurría a
hacerse ahorcar que lo tirara en el
suelo lo arrastraron pero mi hijo es un
niño calmado
no es del estilo de reaccionar y
defenderse cuando lo molestan si hubiese
respondido en aquella época no habría
sido víctima de violencias y ello sigue
haciéndolo reflexionar como
a sus 13 años tuvo amor y está deja de
ir a la escuela se aísla pero el acoso
continúa en línea
el adolescente trata incluso de
suicidarse el día de nuestra grabación
salió para no encontrarse con nosotros
esta es la habitación de mi hijo
actualmente sufre de estrés
postraumático y sigue desescolarizados
vive recluido en este espacio
en la época de los hechos la escuela no
reaccionó su madre sigue molesta con el
sistema educativo para evitar que otros
niños sufran el infierno que su hijo
vivió creó una asociación
[Música]
y ya juega el papel de mediador entre
los padres y la escuela una veintena de
expedientes están sobre su mesa en este
momento en toda la prefectura de saitama
cerca de tokio tanto aquí como en otros
lugares de japón durante los últimos 15
años internet y las mensajerías en línea
han amplificado el fenómeno del email
y golpes insultos humillaciones en las
redes sociales japonesas estos
contenidos sensibles pero virales
circulan libremente
frente a este establecimiento de tokio
algunos alumnos hablan de un efecto de
manada contra el cual es difícil de
luchar
en las escuelas en japon los alumnos
tienen tendencias a crear grupos a
actuar en bandas
creo que esto podría ocurrir en mi
escuela un evento menor puede crecer
cuando es difundido en línea
ya he escuchado hablar de casos de acoso
en la escuela acoso en las redes
sociales o las mensajerías en línea de
hecho es una forma de violencia menos
flagrante y me animé knight
tantas situaciones que esquivan el marco
escolar y pueden provocar lo peor en el
2020 japón tuvo una cantidad récord de
suicidios de jóvenes
499 para luchar contra el acoso de la
escuela esta investigadora creó un
cuestionario entregado al personal de
unas 50 escuelas japonesas permite
identificar mejor a los alumnos víctimas
en un país en el que la salud mental es
un tabú la aplicación en una tableta
facilita la confidencialidad
en japon la escuela es ante todo un
lugar para evaluar calificar o juzgar a
los niños con los profesores les cuesta
hablar sobre sus debilidades o las
emociones que sienten
en la escuela hay un lugar donde pueden
hablar más fácilmente la enfermería en
este liceo todos los alumnos deben
responder el cuestionario tras dos años
de uso esta enfermera se satisface de
los resultados
algunas heridas benignas se esconden
magulladuras más íntimas que adicta una
vez un alumno herido vino y gracias al
cuestionario entendimos que las marcas
que llevaba se debían a una
automutilación y que tenía pensamientos
suicidas
con este sistema pudimos agrandar el
círculo de protección alrededor de los
alumnos así la cantidad de casos de
acoso se hayan triplicado oficialmente
en 10 años en japón esto según ella es
el reflejo de un aumento de las
denuncias una liberación de la palabra
tal vez los primeros frutos de una ley
votada en el 2013 y la ley hizo que se
tomara conciencia en las escuelas la
cantidad de casos de acosos detectados
aumentó porque ahora los adultos son
conscientes de que deben actuar lo antes
posible
una señal alentadora pero en este país
de uniformes se requerirá tiempo para
que la situación mejore la
individualidad y las diferencias son mal
vistas en japón allí un proverbio es muy
popular el clavo que sobrepasa llama al
martillo